all right your ears look good so that
should be the end of this physical oh
great yeah there is one last thing that
we actually have to do okay you know you
know I don't know it's time for the main
show why we're all here
you know what was that you doing like
air traffic signals I need you to drop
them
drop what drop them like it's hot drop
what the lake in time drop them in
Cotham drop your trousers let me see
your tower is that a medical term I got
a cradle your ladle lower your
drawbridge let's see if these lemons
actually make lemonade it's berry
picking season look this isn't easy but
I need to see your peas II hope you used
a breeze cuz I need to squeeze squeeze
what I don't know what it was it's time
to part the forbidden curtain at ease
soldier lower your weapons
look man I'm on a quest achill croc gee
mate I'm going down on down
Corky a Bentley oh no I ain't getting
getting on that one
alright alright four words first word
I'm not good at this game
doctor what what do you need a C I need
to check here my my pulse no but begins
with the P my prostate pancreas your
your pee
that's your pine nuts a pine nuts yes it
a little faster doctor I don't know what
you're saying I need to grab your penis
balls okay your testicles why did you
just say that pine nuts man get it with
pine nuts
[Music]